I can't do a week without lesbian
obesity the federal government spent
about three million dollars on a study
to find out why a lot of lesbians are
obese don't believe me well we've got
some info the NIH study is now in its
fourth year the project seeks to
determine why quote nearly
three-quarters of adult lesbians are
overweight or obese and why gay males
are not the study is slated to last
until 2016 and the total funding for the
project is just about three million
dollars so I don't want to focus on why
lesbians are obese unless quickly you
want to throw do you have no none of us
are lesbians here well I'm I'm not gonna
blame Obama but I am gonna blame the
glue okay so I don't want to focus on on
that part of it but I thought this
brought up an interesting point about
just what the government is spending
money on and just kind of what we let
them spend money on and what we don't
know they're spending money
I don't know this study in particular
but I'm gonna defend science which is
you know when you take a certain
population and you study it you're
trying to remove some factors around it
to make it easier to have your findings
have a little more purity to them
studying people who have a different
genetic makeup or a different I mean you
know of course people want to believe
that lesbians a choice of a lifestyle
but it's it's clearly it's a nature
thing it's not a nurture thing so I
think it's legitimate I think it's
legitimate they're probably studying the
difference between testosterone and
estrogen levels and things like that and
gender I think it's fascinating and I
think it'll it'll it'll pan out it'll
create a lot of information for the
general population but you know they
have they're studying a very small slice
yeah okay so I'm glad you said that
because yes I do believe in science
funding and I don't understand all the
reasons why we do all these studies but
there's probably some relation there but
when I see these things I think the
average person when they see this in the
news they immediately think this is like
we need you know consultants to come in
to the government and
like what the [ __ ] are you guys doing
what really lesbian oh you know really
like is it just is this just one of
these things that just sounds so
ridiculous so that even if there is
scientific worth to it it's it's gonna
get [ __ ] the key word is funding you
know and I read the whole article and I
love the lower lesbians they quoted a
what they would call I guess a
scientific outcome of this was lower
athletic self-esteem the lesbians have
low which which is complete [ __ ] if
you know any lesbians they're awesome in
sports and most and most board games
yeah it's good at board games - oh my
god softball with lesbian well rugby
they're women so they're smart and Jane
Lynch is the game host of America's yeah
game night or whatever it's a Jane Lynch
is a lesbian I'm sorry I'm sorry here's
the thing and then they went on to quote
in the article that because you identify
with a certain you know body type and
you may not go out for sports because
you're not identifying with that group
or you're afraid of being ridiculed so
what does it come back you you said it
earlier it's funding it's not the
funding of this study
it's the funding they cut out of school
it's shop classes when I went to junior
high you had a you had electric shop
metal shop wood shop
you had graphic art design you had at
least a silkscreen shirts now somewhere
in there is a lesbian you know Xanadu
you know and quite frankly if you were
funding that the lesbians could go
through the shop classes find something
that was their passion and go on to be
the next imprint revolution which by the
way is on Pico and they they're gonna
sponsor lesbians I think is what you're
saying
well thinner or fatter is really is
really kind of a there would be higher
self esteem at any weight so we wouldn't
be focused on why are they fat as
opposed to why don't they have hobbies
yeah there are lipstick lesbians too so
you know I'm just making that point and
there are you know 3/4 so you might have
25 per second that's fine and then
there's the metrosexual gay guys and
then there's the bear gay guy I mean you
know this it's a population people yeah
you have in the formative years because
we keep you know again because we're
doing studies like this which art this
has got to be on the
dumbest things I've ever heard ever ever
but it's because then the try hat people
you know the tea people will go now we
got to cut everything so you get like a
jarvis of prop 13 and they cut the stuff
that would help kids to identify with
new groups and to identify with new
things they like yeah that's what you
know you cut shop class well that's why
I wanted to do this segment because I
want people to see that yes this sounds
silly and we can make jokes about it but
to your point we do need science and all
that so last thought on this when I was
reading this I was also thinking this is
kind of like Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory like the NIH I feel like there's
just a lot of [ __ ] going on there that
we don't know about and maybe we
shouldn't know like maybe they're
working on the Everlasting Gobstopper
right now and we can't know about it
right now cuz it's all to that that
science thing so we kind of just have to
let them right we do have to fund some
of this and not know what's going on
thing is you know the way it's supposed
to work is you elect people who oversee
these things people that you supposedly
trust we know they realize the road we
no longer trust the people that oversee
it so therefore we no longer trust if we
went back to the proposal the grant for
this study was that someone's gonna
we're gonna cure lesbianism once we get
them thin you know once they have
options right like you have to really
look at with what's behind this study
which they do not mention they they sort
of like put out a paper yeah I I trust
that you know 90% of the scientists out
there have good intentions to to find
out you know things that are going to
help humanity as a whole I really do but
you know I don't know the NIH and I'm
sure there's a lot of politics and all
of that and you know and yeah it's
ridiculous on paper and it could be
ridiculous and of course the media puts
it out there to make us all mad about it